potential shake-up in the world of
television this is big news in a recent
interview actress Ellen Pompeo who's
portrayed dr. Meredith Grey on the hit
TV show Grey's Anatomy for nearly 14
years said she's definitely looking for
a change that was her quote Pompeo
hinted she could be leaving Grey's
Anatomy within the next two years
well wait wait wait what did you just
say I just I was talking about Ellen
Pompeo I know damn well well you were
talking about look I just want to know
what you said about Miss Pompeyo
I said she's talking about leaving
Grey's Anatomy oh god oh don't think I'm
gonna be sick
why wasn't I consulted I mean there must
be a mistake let me check my phone no
there's no news alerts no text messages
nothing on my Pompeo tracker app well
isn't that just classic Ellen Pompeo
leaving old Andy out in the cold and
looking like an idiot while she drops
the biggest bombshell in TV history
thanks a bunch Ellen
I had no idea you'd be so bad out of
shape about this I'm sorry I even
brought it up well a lot of story is I'm
gonna be in two years when there's a
hole in my heart shaped like the
consummately professional chief of
surgery at grey-sloan Memorial dr.
Meredith Grey she's the only person I've
ever loved any are you sure you want to
say some character on wrong character
you take that back or die at my hand
dr. crane is the lead Tara okay okay
sorry
are you sure you want to say the lead
character on Grey's Anatomy is the only
thing you've ever loved your kids might
be watching Conan if my kids Ellen and
Pompeyo are watching
they know that I'm right and they
understand fully what daddy must do
right now one cruel betrayal big guts
another see this Ellen two-time Teen
Choice Awards nominee Ellen Pompeo i
denounce you
this crowd really hates her - Andy I'm
sorry if it makes you feel any better
Ellen Pompeo she never said she was
definitely leaving lots of stars float
rumors like that just to renegotiate
their contracts and get a little more
money that's all oh oh okay
can I borrow $1,000 for a new phone
excellent show tonight from the glaring
at me it's over
you